good morning everybody and welcome back
who's happy to be here raise your hands
okay
Reuben it is April 18 2023 this is the
Reuben report we are live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and locals share
subscribe tap the notification Bell and
we've got a post game show over at
reubenreport.locals.com I am seriously
psyched for the show today because every
now and again the media and the Machine
and the whole damn thing just hands me
so much stuff that the show basically
writes itself we put it on paper but it
pretty much writes itself uh what we're
going to be doing today is if you have
not seen any of these clips yet Elon
Musk you heard of this guy Elon Musk he
went on Tucker Carlson have you heard of
that guy Tucker Carlson he went on his
show on Fox last night and they
basically started unpacking everything I
mean really going into all of the stuff
that we talk about here related to
government and big Tech related to the
corporate media
related to our corrupt political system
and a whole bunch more and I want to
take that that's going to be sort of the
the linchpin of the show and I want to
connect that to what's going on right
now politically and how we have I really
believe this guys and come along with me
on this crazy adventure we have a brief
moment right now to start writing the
ship there are a couple people out there
I would put Elon at the top of the list
I would put Ron DeSantis right next to
him at the top of that list there are a
couple people out there who are trying
to push sanity back into the system and
I think if enough of us are like oh yes
we remember sanity sanity was good
remember before everyone was completely
bananas and coveted craziness and Trump
derangement syndrome and algorithmic
manipulation and all that stuff remember
what the world was like do you remember
1995 I actually think we can get back to
that and then yeah we're still going to
all have these machines there's still
going to be all the devices and Tech and
there'll be Ai and all of those things
but we will remember something that we
have forgotten something that was really
really good and I I just think there is
a little blip right now where we can
grab it so that's the theme of the show
today uh how not only do you have to
expose it as I often talk about right
you have to expose the nonsense of the
machine but then you have to go on
offense Against the Machine and there
are a couple people doing it right now
but they need your help and I literally
mean you watching this they need your
help before we get to that let's talk
about Birch gold real quick uh you know
inflation has consequences as the FED
raises interest rates to combat out of
control government spending long-term
bonds have diminished in value crippling
banks depositors are holding their
breath and investors are bailing on Bank
stocks diversification has never been
more important the recent surge in gold
prices is tied directly to extreme
Market volatility right now
this is why gold is historically a great
hedge against the stock market and
against inflation that would be a
fantastic time to diversify into gold
with Birch gold group Birch gold makes
it easy to convert an IRA into a 401k uh
sorry an IRA or 401K into an IRA and
precious metals here's what you need to
do visit birchgold.com Dave to get the
free info kit on gold they'll help you
convert your existing Ira or 401K that's
tied to a volatile Market into an IRA
and physical precious metals gold and
silver and the best part it's tax
shelter visit birchgold.com Dave to
claim your free info kit on gold today
they've got an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is who you can trust
to protect your future visit
birchgold.com Dave and now back to me
okay so let's dive right into it Elon
Musk did a rather extensive interview on
Fox last night with Tucker Carl also
we're going to show you a couple
different clips there was an awful lot
there we thought these were the the big
ones to hit on I'm going to start the
show with them and then we'll hit some
again at the end uh first up is uh
Tucker and Elon talking about how Mark
Zuckerberg was sort of once a good lib
and I don't think I have to explain to
you guys there once were good Libs right
the classical liberal position was once
a thing that was involved with say
individual rights and freedom and
freedom of speech and freedom of
Association and all of that stuff JFK
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country the
government's not the answer to
everything those were liberal positions
one day and what Tucker is talking about
here is how that was sort of the idea of
what Zuckerberg said he was but he in
essence unfortunately acts as a Democrat
Party operative
why doesn't Facebook do this I know that
Zuckerberg has said and I take him at
face value that he I I
well I just weigh that he is a kind of
old-fashioned liberal who doesn't like
to censor he has but he you know like
why wouldn't a company like that take
the stand that you have taken it was
pretty rooted in American traditional
political custom you know for free
speech
my understanding is that
um Zuckerberg spent a 400 million
dollars in the last election normally in
a get out the boat campaign but really
fundamentally in support of Democrats is
that accurate or not accurate that is
accurate does that sound unbiased to you
no it doesn't yes
does that sound unbiased to you right so
he used 400 million dollars what he was
saying is this was to get out the vote
to fortify the election to defend
democracy make sure that people are
involved that all sounds good but you
guys know right like that thin veneer
and then right beneath that something
nasty is always there what Zuckerberg in
essence did was do everything he could
to make sure that Democrats won which
party is more favorable to Big Tech I
mean it's very obvious it's the
Democrats not the Republicans that
doesn't mean Republicans are great they
certainly are not we got a couple good
ones but they are significantly as a
whole they are significantly uh better
than the Democrats and Elon Musk as you
know lifelong Democrat never voted for a
republican until the midterms when he
voted for Myra Flores in Texas after
relocating his company Tesla to Texas
for tax purposes so he's had his own
Awakening he's on that journey and it
seems to me that Elon Musk when he gets
to that fork in the road can I go all
the way can I be fully red pilled can I
really fight the system he's going to
pick the right choice we know many guys
right I talk about them all the time who
get stuck at that fork right they either
end up going the wrong way where they
just sort of seemingly end up Stuck In
Perpetual sort of nothingness at that
fork Elon maybe has already gone down
the road which is really beautiful but
the point there is Tucker is saying look
Zuckerberg he's giving him the benefit
of the doubt he says he's an old school
liberal old-school liberals used to like
transparency used to like free speech
why wouldn't Zuckerberg do with Facebook
what you have done with Twitter right
democratize the thing open source the
code which Elon did a couple weeks ago
uh tell people what's been going on
there how the government has been
working with Facebook to silence people
we know that the government's been doing
it we played you the clip a million
times from about a year and a half ago
of Jen saki saying that she works the
administration actually works with
Facebook to flag posts so if the
government calls you up right and you
own a shoe shop and they're like uh you
know that guy who's been buying shoes
for you maybe you shouldn't let them buy
shoes or let them in uh you might want
to do that you might want to do what the
government is requesting because
otherwise the government can come in and
shut you down we're going to revoke your
sales license or we're going to increase
your taxes or whatever it is so it's a
real Mafia move that the government was
doing with Facebook but but in essence
Mark Zuckerberg has basically been okay
with that I'm not even on Facebook I
mean we have a Facebook page for the
show and God bless Brock he has to be on
Facebook are you all right I probably
don't give you enough credit around here
you know what I mean he's upset this guy
he's on Facebook all day long God only
knows what's going on there but you guys
know how manipulated Facebook is and the
crazy range of emotions that it gives
you right there's a picture of Grandma
then a terrorist explosion in the Middle
East then there's a baby picture then
you know this person you know died that
person is getting married like the whole
thing is designed to make you crazy but
in essence what he's saying is okay Elon
Musk is a Democrat operative not that
sort of
forward-facing good liberal that he
purports to be then he went on to talk
about how you've got to root out the
activists at these companies when you
take over that might be why you want why
Mark Zuckerberg hasn't done anything
because he's just got so many of them
but Elon clearly had no problem with it
percentage of your staff did you fire at
Twitter
one of the great business stories of the
year I think we're about we're about 20
of the original size so 80 left uh yes
so I mean a lot of people voluntarily
but sure sure but but it's 80 are gone
from the data that's correct yes so how
do you run the company with only 20 of
the staff
uh it turns out uh you don't need uh
well that many people to run Twitter but
80 that's a lot
um yes uh over I mean if you're not
trying to run some sort of uh
glorified activist organization uh with
it and you're not care that much about
censorship then you can really let go of
a lot of people turns out
thank you
all right so there's a lot to unpack
here you know you guys know I was at
Twitter about two months ago spent some
time with Elon Musk and what's
incredible about the place you know
they've got these massive offices on
multiple floors in this building in San
Francisco he's clearly in the wrong City
but okay one thing at a time also in the
wrong State small steps small steps uh
but you know they've got massive offices
with huge commissaries for food and
lunchrooms and video game rooms and
ping-pong tables and pool tables and all
of these things that have nothing to do
with anyone working they've got beer on
tables but there's no people there so he
bought a very faulty product by his own
estimation right he called that thing a
fractal Rube Goldberg machine the code
in this thing is really messed up the
government was involved in this thing
there were activists at the organization
actively trying to take the company down
he bought it for a cool 45 Bill
something like that right and then he
fired or uh or some of them chose to
leave on their own as he said but about
80 percent of the people are gone so he
bought a faulty product with a whole
bunch of real really bad useless
employees now the thing is slimmer and
trimmer and working and More in line
with the values that you and I share
related to free speech and transparency
and all that so now I want to leave this
to the broader theme that I mentioned
guys I'm telling you it is you versus
the machine and I'm in it with you
elon's in it with you a couple other
people are in it with you but when I
talk about the machine I'm talking about
government and Tech and media so the
next thing that Elon is doing this is
just so beautiful remember a couple days
ago we showed you that clip how NPR
national public radio has now been
labeled state-sponsored media by Twitter
so Elon chose to do that they do get
funding from the federal government and
now NPR is so upset by this that they
they first they lost their blue check
now they say they're not even going to
Tweet okay we'll we'll miss you that's a
joke uh Elon is also in a fight with the
New York Times now the New York Times
which once was all the News That's fit
to print is probably the biggest
purveyor of propaganda
in all of America that's the place where
politicians Democrats go to leak stories
and that's where the lies get laundered
and then it gets disseminated across the
internet so here's Elon and Tucker
talking about what he's doing and how he
feels about the New York Times
New York Times of their of their badge
and then you call them diarrhea okay you
did you did I'm just I'm just quoting
you yeah you described their Twitter
feed as diarrhea I said it was the
Twitter colon Twitter equivalent of
diary okay it's not literally diarrhea
but no it's uh you know it's a metaphor
um
okay so the reason that I thought that
that clip him calling a diary it's not
that it's it's so hilarious it's that
the reason that it's important is
because he's treating them with with the
lack of respect that they deserve I
think at this point where we're at right
now is we have a whole bunch of
politicians even Republicans and
right-leaning people who still think
that if you're nice enough to the New
York Times They will ever treat you
fairly they will not treat you fairly I
would say Donald Trump has a big problem
here he's always feeding the machine
that will never treat him fairly
DeSantis has a different approach to
this Hey NBC you're gonna lie about me
repeatedly you're going to claim I don't
want students in Florida learn about
slavery or civil rights I'm no longer
going to talk to you you have to starve
the Beast Elon by taking this position
of mockery of the New York Times they no
longer have their blue check and also
the New York Times can someone get me
the number they have something like 76
million followers quote-unquote
followers you know but they rarely ever
get a thousand retweets that in essence
means 76 million people who follow them
also ignore them the numbers are
absolutely impossible am I right it's
about 76 what is it 55 I was off by 20
uh but still when we're talking Millions
you get the point uh so this is now a
moment where we've got a little juice
right because literally the world's
richest man the renaissance man of our
time is getting into the fight and he's
not just getting into the fight because
he's out there just screaming about a
bunch of stuff he's buying products that
then strengthen your ability to say
whatever it is you want and that is good
and the Machine ain't happy about it I'm
going to show you a video of one of the
machine's favorites that's Justin
Trudeau up in Canada in just a second
let me talk to you about Phoenix capital
and then we'll get to it guys with banks
collapsing in the turbulent state of the
stock market millions of Americans have
watched their retirement savings
disappear I want to share with you a
unique investment opportunity that's not
only protecting retirement savings but
investors are seeing consistent yields
and growth being Phoenix Capital group
is offering high-value U.S oil and gas
Investments through their corporate
bonds it's a way for people to invest in
energy assets and diversify their
portfolio yields range from 8 to 12 apy
paid monthly with different
qualifications and maturity dates
Phoenix Capital group is a tech-led
Energy company owning in some of the
most lucrative basins Across America
investor Capital along with their own
Capital goes towards cash flow positive
oil and gas projects they had the choice
of offering a significantly lower
interest rate and paying the difference
to middlemen but decided to break the
mold and bring stronger Investments
directly to investors these eight to
twelve percent apoy corporate bonds are
higher than CDs or annuities often more
than double the typical yields so if
you're looking for an alternative
investment with sizable yields and
monthly payment options I highly
recommend checking out Phoenix Phoenix
Capital groups Bond offerings to learn
more download their free investor guide
today at phxon
reuben.com
p-h-x-o-n-rubin.com and let you know let
them know you heard from Dave all right
so what does the machine do when someone
pushes back well the machine starts
freaking out so first off this is
spectacular Elon tweeted this this is
just great uh this is the CBC Canadian
broadcasting corporations official
Twitter account it has now been labeled
labeled 69
government-funded media and you might be
watching that looking at that going 69
69 is a funny number why why'd that
happen uh as Elon said Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation said they're
quote less than 70 percent government
funded so we corrected the label the guy
is not only doing the right thing
calling out government and corporate
sponsored media where it should be
called out he's also having fun doing it
and there was a time guys
for those of you that are of a certain
age there was a time when the internet
was a fun place and the guys ushering
that back in and that's how we'll win
through memes and humor and all of those
things so now the CBC is labeled State
propaganda in essence right NPR will not
tweet the New York Times doesn't have a
blue check suddenly the old structures
what are we always talking about here
these old institutions that are
crumbling and lying to us instead of
strengthening them by giving them
attention and dollars and everything
else he's actually taking their power
away you know who's upset about that
well you've got Justin Trudeau up in
Canada Justin Trudeau is just he's like
the worst of the worst he's basically
Gavin Newsom light and here he is
whining about what that mean mean Mr
Elon Musk did
I think it says a lot about the
Conservative Party of Canada
they're choosing to constantly attack
Independent Media organizations
journalists who are working hard to keep
Canadians informed and support our
democracies
CBC Radio Canada
serves right across the country
delivers local news and local content in
many regions of the country
that in order to attack this institution
that is important for many many
Canadians
he runs to American billionaires
the tech Giants that they continue to
defend in committee
and in their uh in their approach on our
legislation to make Tech Giants pay
their fair share conservatives are
always there to defend them so when
they're trying to attack a foundational
Canadian Institution
the fact that he has to run to American
billionaires
for support to attack Canadians
all right there's so much there so first
off uh he starts by attacking the
Conservative Party of Canada which is
not in power right the Liberals are in
power he's in power despite the fact
that he got something like 33 of the
vote now the conservatives in Canada
might be annoyed by all of this why
would they be annoyed by the uh CBC well
they might be annoyed by the CBC because
it basically just like our New York
Times and MSNBC and corporate press here
is in bed with the Dems the CBC is in
bed with the Liberals go try to find a
positive article about the conservatives
on the CBC or go try to find a positive
article about the Libertarians which is
the Freedom Party of Canada that was my
friend Maxine bernier's party try to
find something that the CBC says nice
about them no they do everything in
coordination with his party so he's very
upset that the conservatives those mean
conservatives and then that billionaire
in America would be pushing back against
his propaganda machine because the left
can't win without a propaganda machine
the ideas don't stand up on their own
Merit right so they need the propaganda
they need people to be confused not
understand what the issues are be
bludgeoned with lies until they
basically just check out all together
um so you might go Dave come on you're
being a little heavy-handed here
um could it possibly be that the
government of Canada that Trudeau is in
charge of pays the uh CBC so much money
that they would do his bidding
well hot damn we've got video of just
that here's 2019 Justin Trudeau joking
about how the Canadian government pays
the CBC a cool 600 million for their
fine journalism
you sometimes hear about liberal bias in
the media these days how they're
constantly letting off our government
letting our government off the hook for
no good reason
frankly I think that's insulting
it's clear that they let us off the hook
for a very good reason because we paid
them 600 million dollars
clear that they let us off the hook for
a very good reason because we paid them
600 million dollars
okay so what does this show us guys as
he's admitting as he's admitting what we
all know right again whether it's
America with our corporate media in bed
with the Democrats or whether it's
Canada with the Liberals in bed with the
CB CBC what does it show us it shows us
that a private citizen like Elon Musk
and you might be again you might be
looking at the guy like basically he's
modern Iron Man could this even be
happening but it is happening a guy he
doesn't have to do this the guy could
literally put his family on a rocket and
go to Mars and that would be that he
could wrap up shop on Earth I'm sure he
thinks about it every now and again but
instead he has decided to get into the
most dangerous fight that there is the
fight for Freedom this is the fight that
humans have been in all time right
fighting for their individual Freedom
against a machine that wants to take it
away from them so a guy like Elon who
now has a private Corporation in Twitter
right it was public he bought it now
it's private uh he can use all of his
skills all of his financial resources
and all of his reach to demolish what I
would say at this point is now the
wicked agenda of the machine so it
doesn't matter whether the machine is
public meaning the government or private
meaning any of these corporations like
Facebook well Facebook's public
corporation but any of these companies
that in essence are trying to squash
your freedom so the question remains can
we wield our own government power
When government is used properly can we
wield our government power to demolish
the machine as well I think we can and
you're not going to believe it I think
it might be emanating first here in
Florida right you don't just need a
private citizen to do it you might find
a public servant who can do it as well
so now let's talk about what's going on
here between DeSantis and Disney we all
know I don't have to belabor the point
you all know what happened over the past
year with uh DeSantis going after
Disney's special protections under the
law they had special tax exemptions they
had their own airport they had all sorts
of special regulations related to them
that would be many would argue uh
anti-constitutional in that everyone
should have an equal playing field
that's what equality is all about so
Disneyland had special exemptions that
for some reason Sea World or Gatorland
didn't have that wasn't fair Disney
decided to fight with DeSantis about
some of this woke nonsense and inject
all of the trans ideology and the race
ideology and all their programming to
Santa to said okay I'm a government I'm
from government I'm not a huge
government big government guy but I will
use the government in a Slim Trim Way
when effective and when appropriate so
I'm gonna I'm gonna hit them so as you
know Disney uh lost a whole bunch of
their uh of their exceptions they lost a
whole bunch of their tax breaks and more
and then the entire corporate press was
suddenly backing a giant corporation uh
in the name of equality something like
that it was very confusing so get this a
couple days before these new regulations
kicked in Disney tried to pass a whole
bunch of things to basically neuter what
the government of Florida was going to
do to Disney and a lot of people were
saying see DeSantis lost C DeSantis lost
so here we go this is from the
Independent on Friday check this out
Florida Republicans remember this is
Friday not today Florida Republicans
will seek to void an agreement granting
Disney nearly Perpetual control of the
land surrounding its Walt Disney World
Resort State Governor Ron DeSantis has
said when Mr desantis's hand-picked
appointees attempted to take control of
District in March they found that their
predecessors had quietly handed their
powers to Disney itself until 21 years
after the death of the last surviving
descendants of King Charles III of
England suffice it to say the
legislature is going to avoid anything
Disney did on the way out the door Mr
DeSantis told students at Michigan's
Hillsdale College but now that Disney
has reopened the issue we're not just
going to avoid the development agreement
they tried to do we're going to look at
things like taxes on the hotels tolls on
the roads developing some of the
property that the district owned so so
just really get this guys this is just a
couple days ago in the last moments
before Disney was going to be under this
new regulation they pass a bunch of
these things to avoid what the
government of Florida decided to do now
let's go to Monday
because on Monday DeSantis did exactly
what he said he was going to do which
he's become quite good at he says
something and then he's going to do it
here he is announcing that Disney is
going to have to do everything that he
said they were going to have to do
uh chapter 163 section 3241 of the
Florida Statutes uh provides the
legislature with the authority to revoke
development agreements in this exact
type of instance and so I've worked with
both uh leaders of the House and Senate
uh there is a bill that will be put out
in the Florida legislature that will
make sure that the agreements purported
to be entered into by Disney uh are
revoked and the people's will is
established and is upheld and that is
something that's very important
and at the end of the day we made the
decision as a state as a people through
the medium of our elections uh that we
would not have one Corporation serving
as its own government that's not good
government and it's not something that
we want to entertain in Florida any
longer and whatever rationale there was
60 years ago to do that clearly now
we're in a much different era as a state
guys I really want to drive home the
point that not only uh is it not easy to
go against Disney like you all may be
watching this going okay well I don't
like Disney because I don't like the
woke stuff I don't like that they were
pushing gender ideology into the
programming like he did the right thing
but first off it's just not easy to do
because of the amount of power and money
and the amount of people that work for
Disney here in Florida can you get the
numbers on that I think it's around 30
000 people if I'm not mistaken in the
Orlando area work for Disney so it was
not an easy choice but by doing the
right thing right by actually fighting
Disney and making sure that all they
have to do is is is abide by the same
laws that everyone else has to abide by
he then as you know went from in 2018
winning by 30 000 votes to then winning
by 1.6 million votes just a couple
months back 70 000 people in Orlando
work for Disney you know you might find
this interesting too when I did uh my
show last June so it's almost a year ago
now it was the last stop on our book
tour and we went and we did that massive
sold out show at the theater in Orlando
um we did it in the belly of the Beast
right because it was at the height of
the don't say gay which game where gay
wasn't in there and all that I had many
many people come up to me after the show
and say Dave you know I work for Disney
and uh you know I don't want people to
know that I'm here but uh we're with you
and I had many many people that said
that after the show Disney as a matter
of fact at this they are the largest
employer in Florida so he took a massive
risk here much like Elon Musk is taking
a massive risk to go against the media
machine to go against the Democrat Party
but when you do the right thing it
becomes contagious and by the way
much like Elon Musk is joking around
about the diarrhea and
the New York Times uh DeSantis is joking
around a bit about what he might do with
some of that land that Disney purports
to control because they don't control it
anymore and the state might have better
uses for it
if you look at this whole special
district Walt Disney Corporation
obviously owns a lot of it but the
district owns other land and you know
quite frankly I wasn't even thinking
about that land uh this was not
something that was really important one
way or another we just wanted them to
live under the same rules pay the debt
pay the taxes all that stuff oh but come
to think of it now people are like well
there's what should we do with this land
and so you know it's like okay kids I
mean people have said you know maybe
maybe have another maybe create a state
park maybe try to do more Amusement uh
Parks uh someone even said like maybe
you need another state prison who knows
I mean I just think that the the
possibilities are are are endless and so
that is now going to be analyzed to see
what would make make the most sense and
um and that wasn't necessarily even on
our on the radar it's kind of hilarious
the idea of a state prison like a
Florida State Penitentiary right next to
Disneyland it seems pretty effective if
you ask me but we shall see but the
point is once again guys if if you are
uh you know married to or have a brother
or a cousin or just a friend who is
confused by this who thinks that
DeSantis is being mean because Disney is
good Disney is Cinderella and Disney is
The Little Mermaid and they are good
guys you must have them understand all
he is doing is revoking special rights
and by the way when I talk about the
type of politician now the type of
conservative politician who will use
government when it is effective to use
it that's what everyone's looking for
what people are not looking for is the
type of politician who watches the
culture wars move on them right and
suddenly your kids are wondering about
their gender identity and all of these
things and it's being pushed through
cultural stuff that Disney is putting
out there and then you get answers like
Mike Pence from a couple weeks ago
remember that video from CNBC we showed
you where they asked Mike pencewell do
you think DeSantis is going a bit too
far by revoking Disney's special access
and and Mike Pence goes yes I'm a
limited government guy it's a bit much
if the government is not there to make
sure we have an even playing field then
there is no purpose of the government in
which case we should all be anarchists
and I think there's probably a growing
movement of that uh but let's focus on
the good here because this is not an
anomaly this moment with Disney where
Disney then at the last second tries to
pull off this crazy thing uh related to
the King right descendants from the King
like it's all complete nonsense Disney
has actually become the bad guy in a
Disney movie but fortunately in Disney
movies you don't get away with it
neither will they uh but this is not an
anomaly from DeSantis this is actually a
movement that is starting and it's
spreading across the country so let's
give another example to add some teeth
here obviously the big controversy last
week was that Bud Light which once was
known as the beer of frat guys and a
bunch of people with funnels doing crazy
stuff uh became the beer of the
transgender movement right they decided
to sponsor Dylan Mulvaney Who We Believe
has a penis but I'm not gonna have
anyone Google it hey you're welcome and
subsequently Bud Light through bad PR
and through deciding we don't like our
actual customers we like the idea of
this genderless customer they've lost
about 7 billion with a B dollars in
market share uh and team DeSantis over
here is having a little fun with that
enjoy
the people also side with us on wanting
to see an economy where businesses focus
on their core missions rather than
indulging in woke political activism and
what you see happening and look some of
it's annoying some of it they're virtue
signaling and it is grading and honestly
I think you know what's going on here
you see Bud Light and doing all this
stuff
but some of this stuff I think is really
Insidious when you look at movements
like ESG environment social governance
what they are trying to do is they're
trying to hijack corporate power in
order to advance in ideological agenda
guys his tone is just right there right
that's actually the way I try to do the
show you know what he's saying that's
annoying and it's virtue signaling right
okay so we can we can mock it and we can
you know call it out for what it is but
it's the Insidious part that is the
problem right it's not that Bud Light in
and of itself working with this trans
person who really is just a LARPing
actor or actress or actor slash actress
it's not that that is so important but
then once it culturally becomes the norm
and then they have third grade teachers
talking to students about transgenderism
and all of this weird stuff and they
hide it from parents which then of
course uh Governor DeSantis stopped with
hb1557 otherwise known as don't say gay
Gay wasn't in the legislation at all
um you can see how it affects people's
lives and then you have some people
who say enough is enough and he happens
to be one of those guys uh he just
yesterday was with Benny Johnson you
know Benny Johnson he's been on the show
many times and they were chatting about
uh the boycotts of Bud Light where this
could all lead
Bud Light gotta get your take on the
boycott so you just brought up
Anheuser-Busch Bud light's getting hit
hit as hard as I've ever seen it you
want to drink Bud's light I mean like
honestly that's like them rubbing our
faces in it and it's like these
companies that do this if they never
have any response they're just gonna
keep doing it so if you as a consumer
are like yeah they're basically and and
I mean it's such a fraud with what
they're doing with that like yeah
they're doing that but I'm just gonna
keep drinking it anyways well then
they're just gonna keep doing it so I
think we have power as consumers to make
our voice heard and not on every company
because sometimes conservative consumers
aren't going to make a dent in some
companies this one is one if you don't
have conservative beer drinkers you're
gonna feel that and so you know I think
it's a righteous uh I think it's a
righteous thing you know some of these
controversies they come up and people
can kind of just say oh well it's kind
of a one-off yet was stupid to do but
it's part of a larger thing where
Corporate America uh is trying to change
our country trying to change policy
trying to change culture and you know
I'd rather be governed by we the people
than than will companies and so I think
pushback is an order across the board
including with Bud Light will we ever
see you drinking a Bud Light again no I
don't think so
guys you see what I'm saying about how
the the political part of what's
happening in America and the cultural
part are connected again it's not that
important what beer you choose to drink
except if you keep funding the very
things that are against the belief
system that you have they will keep
moving on you and then what is
the norm today with this trans craziness
will look like the good old days
compared to the crazy stuff that they
will be ushering in in 10 years so look
as you know I'm not a beer guy I'm a
tequila guy however there are many beers
out there might I recommend a couple
Florida beers for you how about Florida
man beer I've got a whole fridge stocked
with it for our guests we've got Key
West beer we've got high beer Havana
lager La rubia I like that name there
are many Florida beers if you want to
support the good companies of Florida
we've got Funky Buddha there's a lot of
beer out there and why it's not also
like kind of you're the you're the beer
guy around here it's just not good right
it's but is anyone drinking a Bud Light
like that's the best beer I've ever had
I don't know why I'm talking like this
when I'm drinking beer but like it's
known as not a grape beer that's why
kids in college drink it because they
don't have any money so just goodbye
sorry sorry Anheuser-Busch sorry Bud
Light you stepped in it and we are going
to push back not only politically by
electing the right people but culturally
by putting our money where our mouth is
so what is the message that I'm trying
to convey to you today in case I haven't
laid it on thick enough the point is
guys we have options and we actually for
the first time we have alternative
Solutions okay in the past two years all
of us the freedom loving Community
whatever that is that broad conservative
thing that I'm always talking about I
think we're starting to realize that
when we go on the offense the real
offense regardless of our political
opinion regardless of whether we agree
exactly on the weeks on abortion or what
the exact tax rate should be or whatever
it might be when we start going to the
offense not only can we win we'll win
politically like the Santa's crushing it
in Florida but then we will we will spur
other people to do the right thing Elon
Musk didn't buy Twitter just like he
woke up one day and was like I will
solve that problem
he saw a problem bubbling he saw what
people were saying on Twitter he saw the
government overreach then he had to go
to his banker and be like hey can we
figure out 44 bill that's going to be
tough but then we start winning and I
really believe we can win the government
we can win the big Tech fight we can win
the media fight we can win the consumer
economy fight we can we actually can win
all of it so how do we do it how do we
do it now sort of politically now let's
go purely to the political part of it
well
again we're going to stick here in
Florida for a moment because I think
it's very obvious that this is the
answer so what has uh DeSantis been
doing for the last couple days besides
this because it is a DeSantis focused
situation right now uh here he is
talking about what we all should be
advancing right now
we fight the woke in the legislature we
fight the woke and the corporations we
fight the woken the schools we never
ever surrender to the woke mob we have
made Florida the state where woke goes
to die
the woke mind virus represents a war on
Merit it represents a war on achievement
it's a form of cultural Marxism that
seeks to use identity politics to divide
Americans but perhaps most of all
the woke represents a war on the truth
and as a leader I don't seek adulation I
don't seek any Fanfare all I'd seek is
the pursuit of the truth okay as you
guys know because we played a clip of
that yesterday that is Liberty
University it is the largest Evangelical
college in the United States that is
their Sunday convocation 14
000 students in that room right there I
did a talk there right before covet it
was one of the most incredible events
that I've ever been part of uh I am not
thought of as someone that might be
welcomed with open arms in a traditional
line of thinking with evangelicals a gay
married man who's begrudgingly
pro-choice but I talked about all of
that and I got nothing but love from
those people and many of those students
afterwards who came up to me and said I
said Dave I have some differences with
you but thank you for coming here thank
you for sharing your feelings so when
DeSantis goes there and talks about how
the woke are fighting truth
uh they hear that they hear that and I
think you hear it and it doesn't and and
that's the point that evangelicals can
be now on the same side as the
disaffected liberal and the libertarian
this is the big political movement that
could include somebody like Ron DeSantis
that could include someone like me
someone like Elon Musk someone like the
average Evangelical Christian and it
makes sense it's actually not that hard
to piece together so this is the driving
thesis of what we're trying to do right
now because now I can see the political
movement right we've all been trying to
put these pieces together but this is
what we should all be putting together
it is the fight for truth and for
Freedom now I want to contrast that a
little bit and I know some people are
not going to be happy with me but that's
what DeSantis has been doing for the
last couple of days right he's been
fighting and making sure that Disney
does not skirt the floor the laws of
Florida and he's going to an Evangelical
College to talk about truth here's this
is what Donald Trump was doing yesterday
on Truth social since leaving Washington
I haven't heard much about lady Mick
Mulvaney perhaps the dumbest person
along with John Bolton working at the
White House he was acting Chief of Staff
because I never would have named him to
the permanent position merely a back
bencher who once gave a news conference
that was legendarily bad he is now with
CBS fake news and should be grateful to
the man who made him famous this guy was
uncharismatic a born loser no wonder why
they have no ratings exclamation point
uh Trump hired Mick Mulvaney Trump also
hired John Bolton but you see what I'm
trying to show you guys we can get to
the new world he can't get us there he
can't get us there look he might be the
nominee and if he is the nominee I'll
support him because I'll support any
Republican truly over a Democrat
obviously but do you see if if you are
willing to see it the new world is
trying to be born right now and
unfortunately Trump is not of the new
world who cares about that nonsense are
you trying to tell us you're so great
because you hire morons what are you
what are you telling us really and that
is the fundamental difference there is
someone doing the work right now it is
what we have been asking for what do I
keep saying we want Clarity we want
competency and we want communication
and I think we have it I think we have
it so is that what you want to be part
of clarity compensity competency and
communication or do you want to be part
of of crazy posts on Truth social
making fun of people that you you hired
right okay so who else guys has taken
charge by disregarding public opinion
going on offense chasing virtue and
absolutely not giving any flying F's
well we'll get you back to the beginning
of the show it's about Elon Musk guy
let's go back uh to that interview with
Tucker Carlson here he is talking about
how he's going to protect your digital
identity because one of the things that
he found out is that the government
actually was able to look at your DMs
that's right the government could look
at your private messages so he's going
to figure out a way to encrypt that so
even he will not be able to read your
private passages
you can see what it is and you can see
what they've been doing and you can see
who's been working there you you were
shocked to find out that various Intel
agencies were affecting its operations
uh the the degree to which uh various
government agencies had effectively had
full access to everything that was going
on on Twitter uh blew my mind I was not
aware of that would that include
people's DMs
uh yes
yes because the dams are not encrypted
so one of the first you know one of the
things that we're about to release uh is
the ability to encrypt your DM that's
pretty heavy duty though because a lot
of well-known people reporters talking
to their sources government officials
the rich people in the world they're
dming each other
and the Assumption obviously was
incorrect but was that that's private
but that was being read by various
governments uh yeah that seems yes
scary uh yes it is so like I said we're
moving to
um have the DMS be optionally encrypted
I mean you know there's like a lot of DM
conversations which are you know just
chatting with friends it's not not
important
um there's hopefully coming out later
this month but no later than next month
uh is the ability to toggle encryption
on or off so if you if you are in a
conversation you think is sensitive you
can just toggle encryption on and then
no one on Twitter can see what you're
talking about they could put a gun to my
head and I couldn't I couldn't tell I
couldn't
the the that's that sort of gun Fair
test if somebody puts a gun to my head
and I can I still not uh see your DMs
that should be that's the acid test yes
okay so it's worth noting a little bit
of the technical part of what he's
talking about there when you have
end-to-end encryption that is me sending
say Phoenix a message we have end-to-end
encryption no middleman can decipher
what that message said now it doesn't
mean we're doing anything illegal we're
usually talking about what we're going
to do on the show which I assume will be
deemed illegal in about 10 years if we
lose this fight but the point is you
want to be able to communicate with who
you want to communicate with about
whatever the hell you want to be able to
communicate about without anyone else
being there so Elon is saying we will
encrypt these messages so I will have
literally no way gone to my head of of
uncovering that information right I
would say the second he rolls this thing
out everyone should have all their
conversations be encrypted why even if
you're talking about nothing if you're
talking about Beanie Babies is that a
that's a cot reference these days right
Beanie Babies even talking about Beanie
Babies why should anyone at Twitter or
the government be able to know what
you're saying about beanie babies and
now you've wasted the family fortune on
Beanie Babies okay I think you see the
point let's go a little further with
this uh because what this all really is
about is that Elon Musk once again the
world's richest man is saying I see the
problem
it's very much the same problem that the
census has been talking about and I am
going to do everything possible to push
back against the Deep State and the
government and the entire machine that
isn't that is seemingly coming for all
of us
and that's how that's that's how it
should be if you want have you had
complaints from various governments
about doing this
I haven't had Direct complaints to me
I've had sort of like some indirect
complaints I think people are a little
concerned about complaining to me
directly in case I tweet about it
you know
they're like oh
so they're sort of trying to be more
roundabout than that you know I mean if
if I got something that was uh
unconstitutional from the US government
I would say my reply would be to send
them a copy of the you know First
Amendment
and just say like what part of this are
we getting wrong
do you see why the machine freaked out
when this guy said he was going to buy
Twitter why the board of Twitter tried
to stop him from buying Twitter because
it had very little to do with being a
profitable company Twitter was purging
money but there was another value in
Twitter the other value in Twitter for
big Tech
was your data and for the government was
what you were talking about and they
wanted to make sure that they were not
going to sell the company to him and
then thank God I mean it really is a
beautiful thing you have to understand
this the board when Elon came in and
said we will buy Twitter at a premium a
price that this thing is not worth
because it's not a profitable company I
will pay you a premium on this the board
said no but eventually the shareholders
were like whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a
second wait a second I invested in this
company you've got Elon Musk the richest
guy in the world willing to buy this
freaking thing at a premium and you're
not going to sell to him why not don't
you have a fiduciary responsibility to
us the shareholder So eventually they
begrudgingly did it but now you see why
they were so against selling to him
because this is the front line in the
war against their censorship he's
telling everybody he's putting a warning
shot out there hey government next time
you contact me so that you know if coven
7 comes around and you want me to
silence you know Dr J about acharya or
or Brett Weinstein or somebody else I'm
going to send you back a picture of the
Bill of Rights how about that how about
that so do you see why they didn't want
him to have it and do you see why Mark
Zuckerberg who has Facebook wants to
keep the control going I think you do
because you're bright it's a rhetorical
question so let's do some bigger picture
stuff how are we going to crush the
machine uh right this moment and into
the future well a little freedom of
speech a little even playing field a
little honest uh interaction between the
people without algorithmic manipulation
might have a little something to do with
it musk talked about that as it relates
to the next election
you're saying but you're kind of exposed
in your other businesses so this is just
in case reviewers aren't following this
this is not you're not just like a
journalist taking a stand on behalf of
the First Amendment you're a guy with
big government contracts giving the
finger to the government do you think
um
Twitter will be as Central to this
presidential campaign as it was in the
last several I think it will play a
significant role in elections not just
domestically but internationally the
goal of new Twitter is to be
um as fair and even handed as possible
so not favoring any political
uh ideology but uh just um
yeah being being uh being fair at all
what is Elon Musk strike you as an
extremist does he strike you as a
right-wing Maniac hey guys I'd like to
make this thing kind of fair we're not
going to favor anybody we're going to do
as much honest assessment uh when it
comes to information and political
ideology as possible now he hasn't
accomplished all that I still have my
own frustrations with Twitter I still
think the algorithm is a little screwy
the the For You tab is out of whack okay
fine but the guy is clearly trying to do
the right thing and just look if you
look at from the time that he got
Twitter or even if you look at the two
three weeks maybe even month or so
before he got Twitter to today look at
the press that this guy gets from the
mainstream that he's far right he's in
bed with white supremacists let's not
forget by the way he's African-American
from South Africa so they're treating an
African-American rather poorly uh you
know that Twitter suddenly everyone
started freaking out that Twitter had a
child porn problem which it does have a
problem he's now doing something about
it the same people who never wrote
articles about Twitter child porn
problem before Elon never wrote about it
once suddenly when Elon took over 20 is
a massive child porn problem they lie
about everything and they are freaking
out that they have lost control of
perhaps the most important app related
to how we all communicate with each
other that is not me telling you to get
on Twitter it really is not because if
you're not on there I don't think
wasting any more time on these things is
worth it
um but we have a little
we have a little nugget now that we can
do something with that maybe a little
seed let's say that maybe we can put
into the ground and if we water properly
and we make sure it gets them the right
nutrients that it could grow into
something really great so what do we
have to do guys we have to pillage and
colonize the old systems take what is
good and there is some good stuff there
and now bring it into the new world
build new systems how about how about we
build an Empire maybe an Empire of
Freedom how does that sound there's got
to be a video game called Empire Freedom
there must be right sounds like
something but guys I'm telling you we
can do it whether it's Elon Musk whether
it's Ron DeSantis whether it's Tucker
Carlson
whether it's me whether it's you there
is this wide thing happening
but we got to let the old things go it's
just the truth
but if you don't agree with me
I'd like to hear from you why don't you
join us in live chat in about a minute
from now at rumble.com no at
reubenreport.locals.com but I hope you
subscribe at rumble.com Ruben report by
the way my full interview with Richard
Dreyfus legendary oscar-winning actor
Richard Dreyfus who is far more
interested in talking about Civics and
education than anything related to
acting uh part one is up right now the
full thing's up at locals uh we leave
you with a cold close with that Elon
Musk guy and we will see everybody on
locals in just about a minute thanks
[Music]
let's go